the White House is denying that
political connections led to a contract
to restore electricity in Puerto Rico
the multi-million dollar contract was
awarded to a small electrical company in
Whitefish Montana
that's the hometown of interior
secretary Ryan's inky in a statement
Zinke said he had quote absolutely
nothing to do with the contract the
White House says the decision was made
exclusively by the Puerto Rico Electric
Power Authority
David beg no traveled to the company's
headquarters on Friday and on his way
back he ran into some trouble when
another driver blocked the road he's in
Whitefish Montana this morning David
what exactly happened good morning we
believe that man is related to the CEO
of whitefish energy he cut us off as we
were trying to leave the company
headquarters and blocked us from leaving
he also called the Sheriff's Department
and a responding deputy lectured the man
as to why he could not block people like
that and the man left there are about
7,200 people who live here in whitefish
montana and one of the best-known
residents is ryan Zinke the interior
secretary mister zenki has said he had
nothing to do with the company getting
to contract The Associated Press reports
Zink he knows the CEO of whitefish
Energy because at one time Zinke son
worked for the company we found what's
believed to be the headquarters here in
rural Montana but it looks like a
private residence that one-story wooden
house is the home of whitefish energy
the tiny energy company with only two
full-time employees surprised many
people when it received a 300
million-dollar no bid contract to help
rebuild Puerto Rico's electrical grid
Whitefish has never worked on a project
this size if you look around I mean
we're kind of in the middle of nowhere
it's beautiful out here but certainly
doesn't look like a headquarters for an
energy company hi i'm andy tech Manske
founder and CEO of fish energy whitefish
CEO Andy tech Manske says his company
has 300 workers on the ground in Puerto
Rico working to fix a crippled
electrical grid a month after Hurricane
Maria devastated Puerto Rico's 75% of
the island
is still without power this is a
contract that was determined by the
local authorities in Puerto Rico on
Friday White House press secretary Sarah
Huckabee Sanders tried to distance
President Trump from the contract on the
same day the president addressed the
issue with interior secretary Ryan Zinke
he did ask such secretaries Enki just
for clarification purposes and he
reiterated once again that we have no
role the federal government and
specifically he had no role in that
contract the contract states that the
Federal Emergency Management Agency FEMA
reviewed and approved the agreement but
FEMA says it was not involved and any
language that says it was is inaccurate
the controversy over the contract set
off a Twitter feud between the mayor of
San Juan harmony lien Cruz and the
company Cruz believes the deal with
whitefish energy should be voided
she described the company as inadequate
and asked for transparency but whitefish
hit back threatening to leave writing
quote we've got 44 linemen rebuilding
power lines in your city and 40 more men
just arrived do you want us to send them
back or keep working the company later
apologized
whitefish says that will fully cooperate
with any requests from a government
agency wanting to know more about how it
got the contract and it says it's proud
of the work it's doing in Puerto Rico
Anthony I want to quote you some of the
rates that whitefish is paying to its
subcontractors 319 dollars an hour for a
journeyman lineman and 286 dollars an
hour for a mechanic David big no in
Montana thanks